there's a sign at ramit Park that says
do not drink the sprinkler water so I
made sun tea with it and now I have an
infection
sir sir are are are are you listening to
me sir sir I'm talking to you sir sir
are you aware that there is waste in
your water
system Ron you have to help me Chris is
making me do some stupid Management
training leadership course now that you
run the anal Control Department you have
qualified for the Chris Trager
Management training seminar or kumps
it's not a great acronym but it is a
great Seminar can you get me out of it
yes normally if given a choice between
doing something and nothing I'd choose
to do nothing but I will do something if
it helps someone else do nothing I'd
work all night if it meant nothing got
done Ron Swanson and April lgate
literally my two favorite people in the
catalog Universe April will not be
participating in your pointless course
because she has more important things to
do like not participating in your
pointless course I just want April to
become as greater department head as
yourself which is why this is pointless
I've been head of the parks department
for 12 years and I never had any
Management training course Ron you've
never been cpsed I am legally required
to kumps every department head otherwise
we are open to all kinds of liability
what are you saying I'm saying that
tomorrow during the seminar April is
going to have a classmate and spoiler
alert it's Alf it's
you this went poorly if any of you need
anything at all too bad deal with your
problems yourselves like adults I would
prefer that she ask me for my permission
so I can say no I like saying
no it lowers their
enthusiasm okay so the clue is inside
but it takes the felet code to open
Andy did you try
H yes why is that everyone's first
suggestion just smart people I think I
might be able to help you told
[Music]
you let me see it yeah you can I'll show
you I can unroll it the murals With This
Heart you see look to the first and
there your next clue will be the first
letter of the name of each mural with a
heart on it will spell out the
clue or some or something let's check
out the murals Okay so we've got other
ones from this side with the heart
sticker all right the ones from the
other hallway are cornfield Slaughter
lament of the Buffalo needless Slaughter
Slaughter gone wrong eating the Reverend
its rainning blood and death everywhere
great I got it from here thanks guys I
hope I didn't screw up your Valentine's
Day Too Much oh God no April hates
Valentine's Day and brunch and outside
and
smiling she's weird I figured it out the
letters unscrambled say no food
finer clue three at JJ's Diner how many
Clues are there
[Music]
exactly I found this typewriter next to
the Courtyard dumpster an old Underwood
five with original carriage
return took her home polished her up
bought a brand new ribbon off of
electronic bay.com
okay somebody's got to do something I'm
getting a cluster headache oh he's
leaving let's go I'm going to throw it
away no I'm not it weighs a billion tons
what is he typing anyway if you sons of
try to remove this typewriter
I'll kill
you I'm going to type every word I
know
rectangle
America
megaphone Monday
butthole
hello
hello can I help you hi my class is here
on a field trip and I'm supposed to
interview someone for a school project
okay you can wait at that table and
someone will be here
sometime but aren't you here
now
no look little girl can we postpone this
for another day it's unsettling having
you just sit there what my reports do
tomorrow what's it on why government
matters really it's never too early to
learn that the government is a greedy
piglet that suckles on a taxpayer's
teeth until they have sore chapped
nipples I'm going to need a different
metaphor to give this
9-year-old what's your name ma'am Lauren
burus
Lauren my name is Ron Swanson and I'm
going to tell you everything you need to
know about the miserable screwed up
world of local
government you mustard in your mustache
don't sass me burkus let's get started
life liberty and property it's John
Lock in the time I've worked here I've
taken great pains to see as little of
this building as possible turns out the
third floor is silent empty and
completely free of government
work I can't think of anything more
beautiful to share with my
son if I had a toolbox I could take care
of that faulty
radiator this place is a paradise just
as we suspected John we repaired the
valve stem seal and now All That Remains
is to tighten down this packing
nut and that should do it can we help
you no we have everything under control
my Crews reach doing this whole floor
we're the only people allowed up here
right now we proceed with your work you
won't notice us at all he's a big guy I
man forget about working I just want to
stare at this baby all day what is the
nature of your work on this floor total
redo new floors fixtures Plumbing how
long will it take 6 to 8
weeks deal I will do all this work for
you in the time allotted just have your
tools and materials brought up
here
Ron what are you doing here the most
important government work I've ever done
sanding rat urine stains out of this
floor what are you doing here I'll say
it again the men's room needs a separate
dispenser for face wash I can't wash my
face with hand soap look at these pores
they're gaping hey guys time out let's
take a brief recess can we help you an I
was looking for lesli but now I'm
curious why you guys are sitting around
doing nothing and getting drunk at work
it's the wine and cheese Club gorgeous
it's a monthly Gathering where we all
get together and vent about what annoys
is at work over Fine Wines and cheeses
of course Larry salami the human
resources department requires that I be
available once a month to discuss
workplace disputes with my employees the
rules do not specify whether or not I'm
allowed to Listen to Willie Nelson on my
headphones and Kyle parked his car in my
spot again now that is the fourth time
this month hello I'm sorry everybody
makes mistakes look at me he thinks
he's go for today I just want to choke
him until he passes out I've been quite
open about this around the office I
don't want this parks department to
build any parks because I don't believe
in government I think that all
government is a waste of taxpayer money
my dream is to have the park system
privatized and run entirely for profit
by
corporations like
Chuck-E-Cheese they have an impeccable
business model I would rather work for
Chuck-E-Cheese well I will definitely
think about it I like the sound of that
definitely I'm going to leave before you
change your
mind Ron Swanson it is my pleasure to
inform you that you are a finalist for
the job of assistant city manager Chris
I feel I should remind you that I do not
believe that the position or the entire
government should exist that said you'd
be a fool not to pick me I will walk
deeper into the belly of the Beast if it
means I'm able to further limit Reckless
government spending I mean I have so
many ideas some are simple like take
down traffic lights and eliminate the
post office the bigger ones will be
tougher like bring all of this crumbling
to the
ground